i am so much better than sean
at making cloak promos that man doesn't
know the first
thing about even wearing clothes
let alone promoting them here's a real
authentic picture of mr jacksepticeye
himself
doing his darndest to promote cloak
oh you hate to see it
but i understand he only learned how to
spell a few years ago
well started to learn
[Music]
so instead of listening to him scream
your ear off about our great new lineup
why not listen to my sultry smooth
voice tell you all about our new piece
by piece collection
available right now at cloakbrand.com
link in the description don't even
bother checking
sean's silly little promo it's not worth
your time
or the inevitable brain damage instead
go to cloakbrand.com to check out all
the amazing new clothes we have in store
for you
link in the description cloakbrand.com
see you soon bye
we're gaming wait please god wave your
arms around
read the tutorial oh it's working
lipstick
grab the platform uh okay yeah it's like
mount your friends wait imagine it's
like mounting your phone
oh god no no no no not like that don't
don't get any preconceived notions yeah
i mean it's not like mounting your
friends
let's go for a little let's go for a
little dangle everyone let go i got this
god
you look at my face yeah you're really
holding on
oh jesus okay it's fine this is fine
you're holding on to something yeah
[Laughter]
all right now bob don't let me go don't
let me die i don't want to die i don't
let go of anything
yeah look at those sweet balloons hey
it's a record guys
yeah we did it we didn't all right
my ass no why do you guys just want to
grab onto things let's do gymnastics
together oh
okay bob let go
okay here we go jesus
we're swinging who is who on here who's
blue oh my
okay okay can you guys tell me who's who
you're orange was that clear
okay i'm orange you're orange
i'm green we're all the colors of our
channel i'm blue get
oh my face i feel like
i feel like you did that to us i wanted
to be friends
[Music]
it you gotta grab it we can catch him we
got it we got it we're [ __ ] wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
you're halfway okay it's fine hold on
gotta get in here wait wait wait
wait we had a 500 mile head start
how do you like that nerd it's like
grabbing you by the beach
okay watch this just don't touch i'm
coming in i'm going for it baby oh [ __ ]
well that's about right i'm sorry
it's flailing around wildly what you
were hoping for oh oh
there you go wait i got you
[Applause]
sir
i got you you what okay good
great what does that mean so i'll i'll
grab okay
no come here there you go there you go
okay here we go
oh boy
[Applause]
jesus christ
i knew what i was doing
[Music]
because we don't need it all right all
right well you [ __ ] want to die
no why oh
all right how did you even do that i
don't know
like shot at
why are you all so clumped up you know
what i got it
let's go we got it we got it we got it
go
lunch yeah i know i think you should try
and throw it in i think that'll pop
it out
that was such a good throw how did you
[ __ ] not make that work
are we are we launching here we go all
right you guys
trust me you guys trust me okay come
here three two one we're going oh
[ __ ] oh no
okay mark you need something you need to
what do you mean i need to grab with my
left okay fine
there you go
okay mark how's it going you wanna get
that coin you wanna try and launch
yourself across yeah
of course of course i do all right guys
here we go
all right you trust me here we go
oh why am i the one holding things
i got it i got it i got it let it go
oh wait wait wait wait wait oh [ __ ]
oh okay
oh hi mark are you guys ready yeah
okay here we go stop fighting the
momentum
so oh crap something blades oh
no we don't we don't need the point you
were on the end you were the grabber
yeah there's the grabber
[Laughter]
oh
oh my god
[Laughter]
nothing but net on that one yeah i used
to play basketball i'm pretty good at
this
i just want to say that one wasn't a new
record okay this one
this one is annoying i got you
i got you okay thank you thank you lori
okay wait i have you
going i do mark can you like move up
or something here we go
don't let go of me because i'm not
holding on
there we go okay we're good all right
we're good here we go ready for this
here we go
wait oh
oh crap
god damn it i told you this one's hard
it's not hard
we're just dumb i do i do feel like i
should explain
wade in the air whatever way you're
holding
the joystick affects the whole
[Applause]
oh buddy okay i got it i got it don't
let go don't
there we go all right we're gonna swing
around yeah
oh okay oh
[Applause]
i feel like people are fighting the
momentum in the air we need to all work
together i'm trying to swing with you
guys however
you swing left we need more ups yeah
that's what confuses me when
i think i don't think you're swinging in
the right direction because there's
definitely
some weird someone is someone is
fighting the upward momentum
well why do you guys automatically
assume it's me cause you're there
all the way to the end we can do it we
can make it all the way to the end all
the way to the eye
yeah we can make it just leave leave the
momentum to me
i can swing all of us
what the [ __ ] were you thinking i don't
know man
i don't understand hey it's a new record
i was not in agreeance of that did you
hear me say okay
[Applause]
i said i was on my own well not now why
don't you let go
i will turn this mess around you
oh why did you spawn over here
wait what why am i over here get off of
me
don't let go oh god
oh god okay we're alive we're alive
everything's fine we're fine
everything's cool
guys let's get right there
no no run we're
[Laughter]
okay i got it i got it no you don't got
it i thought
i thought i did i oh for [ __ ] sake
okay all right keep going keep going
come on don't let him on keep going
yeah we gotta go we gotta go i can't
i'm stuck why can't we
oh no you're not moving on my screen
i can't move i think my game's crashing
i can't i don't know what we're holding
on to i don't know who's holding up
i'm not holding on anything anything
everything's frozen
and dead oh no oh no oh my game crashed
hardcore
oh
okay okay for leaving me i killed kill
wade
me bring him with us not kill him oh
okay
i'll grab him i'll grab him okay you'll
snatch him okay i got him i got him
again
all right guys the grabber needs to be
in the middle this isn't this isn't how
this is
let me let me i'll get him yeah there
there you go well this doesn't help it's
not no this doesn't work
i got gotta it's okay here we're gonna
wait for all the mirrors
invited i got it okay i'm letting go
okay here's the end and i am the end
here we go got it
oh that kind of doesn't oh that's sorry
that's me sorry it's fine it's
oh that that's it that's it you just
gotta whip them out of the way
oh
this stone cold corpse all right what if
we what if we what if i launch us
jack can you fight my mom i've got it
holy [ __ ] okay bob let go wait wait wait
wait wait
bob i'll grab it with my right
[Applause]
hand holy [ __ ] how did that work
i don't know the last second
holy [ __ ] that was so
we got you in there wade oh good i'm i'm
glad
i'm going to see if i can invite you
back right now
[Music]
let go of my ass oh my ass baba
okay
[Laughter]
let me get
anything that i'm definitely not gonna
do it's let you get the egg
let me get the egg no are you kidding
are you kidding me that's like the coin
here
it's the coin you're going back that way
wait come this way no i thought we were
in the egg we're getting the out yes
we're getting the egg
here let me get this right okay a little
more weight that egg
that egg pooped on me i got it i got it
i'm gonna grab it i'm gonna grab oh it's
on this side
okay i've got it hold on to it it's two
no wait grab it grab it grab it with
your left
you can't [ __ ]
okay okay okay oh i want an
egg that one now i have a heart attack
i'm covered in [ __ ] i don't like it
okay egg
oh god and there goes bob ah get the egg
stop
you got it
oh
hang on gotta get some speed we'll catch
you bye guys
it's easier to go the other way i gotta
get some speed what do you mean you
gotta get your speed
bob you know how physics works don't you
hang on i need some speed
you hate to see it oh god you can't oh
wow all right [ __ ] it nerds wow
okay with that [ __ ] you're a legend
here we go don't worry i got a hand free
i got these
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna get the egg
don't worry watch this watch this i got
the eggs
drill drill drill drill wait let's go
right okay
okay bob eggs
egg what about i don't need you losers
holy [ __ ] i have i have 400 hours in
this game i'm controlling
you this whole time oh something like
that i got a few minutes whoa what the
wait guys what yeah wait you got to do
this you don't see it
okay
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
what the hell that was such an accident
that was every moment of that was afraid
all my [ __ ] skill to do that accident
my ass all right bobby you got the egg
you got the egg no hang on let me use my
right hand
take my hand i'm kind of stuck in this
situation here
hang on i got you i got it grab
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right guys gosh i get it i get it i
get it now
oh god all right
it's fine
no you don't get to be on the end this
time you're you're excited
for the egg i'm the one getting us ready
to go
slowing us down i got it got it wait
can you hand it to my left hand mark
yeah here i got it i got it why do you
i don't know don't have it let go let go
let's go let go of the egg
it's all fine let go of the eggs let's
go like i had the aggie
i got the egg smart fine fine fine
oh wait so i'm on the end we never
pulled the rope before what does the
rope do got it
on the road to a mini game make as many
baskets as possible oh
no what oh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what oh we're going uh we're going
guys
oh oh that's where they are
who got one in oh wait what i lost my
balls
wait let go of my ball wait what are you
doing
wait you don't dunk yourself wade
what lift your arms you [ __ ]
god damn it i haven't gotten a single
one in i got one
two i got two i got two ends
wait get out let go of me
wait why are you in how are you dying
wade
oh god i [ __ ] suck you're not
american it's okay
oh wow wait why are you down here when
it's over
do not you grab onto the wall you grab
onto the ball
oh hold hold hold hold hold hold there
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa holding
grab the egg grab the egg wade no wait
wade's left
grab no this is right it's his right
it's his right
no way that's not it that's not it i
there we go you were right there here
comes the bird oh god all right here we
go
we're going forward yes
pull me in okay okay so
i wasn't very good at basketball guys
just in case you didn't notice
you weren't very good at staying alive
[Laughter]
oh god okay okay guys oh
yeah just guys guys guys guys guys wait
wait what's the plan here guys what's up
oh wait come on mark why'd you do that
okay there we go i'm going for it get
off of me
you're gonna get electrocuted we're
going for it ah
don't touch me wade get away from me
just don't
don't touch me like on me
i had let go you were the one holding on
i was not holding on
wait i don't believe that for a second
come here wait no
you can't go under you're going to get
dated no it's timed you idiot what's up
morons you need some
you need some hot tips
[Laughter]
wait did you think you were me get off
of me
why why wade why
you're so dead no we're not let go okay
we're in now
look i'm good mark but it doesn't change
the fact i didn't want you to be part of
what you're doing
[Laughter]
casually eats we could have had that
coin you should have had that coin why
didn't you get the coin john
i will kill your first point oh god well
i choose left before i understand what's
happening i'm going left
it's time to go down here i don't got
you buddy
i didn't want to touch you i didn't want
to touch you
oh god oh god oh god please help oh god
help me help me help me somebody help me
oh god hey what's up mark hey how's it
going man hey man how you doing
hey hey what's up please let me go wait
do you want some assistance
wait you better hurry up love you
[Laughter]
here i'll get you another one there bud
all right
your hands are backward oh hang on
oh god oh god oh oh you were so cold
why aren't you why don't you crap i
don't understand
bob hurt wade hurt
i almost saved him well all right here
comes your chance
all right all right wait write it down
i'll totally grab you
it's fine yeah okay here you go okay
i don't want to be a part of this
you have to do something wayne all right
all right he's following gps into the
lake right now
yeah go away i'm here as a safety net
safety net [ __ ] building know of
everything and stop moving
[Laughter]
i literally had to grab you by your face
that's weird
teamwork get off me wade [ __ ] get
i don't know die oh my god
just go wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait guys guys guys guys
guys
guys i don't want to be there i don't
want to go
you forgot about the most important
member of the band
ah wait let go
wait climb
do you guys need some assistance i need
to get weight off me assistant
let me go i got you i got you i lift
your hand up i'm reaching i got you guys
all right i got let go of everything
[Laughter]
i don't want to touch your hand jesus
christ
don't don't touch me oh please don't
touch me
sort of don't block wade from getting in
here
don't you [ __ ] dare
[Laughter]
i will drag you by the [ __ ] ass if i
have to
don't you [ __ ] dare grab them with
both hands
if you work if you were drowning in the
ocean wade would
climb on your shoulders and just shove
your head underwater
there
[Laughter]
yeah we're doing this baby we're doing
all right we're making it happen wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa
wait it's gonna go
go higher though don't let him touch us
the disease get away from you you're
good you're good you're good you're good
okay no okay i'm gonna i'm gonna take
this for the team mark you go
all right cool i got this watch this
[Laughter]
why did you abandon me mark
mark jump to me i'll catch you okay no i
can do this i can make this happen
i can make it happen i made it happen
flee
all right i'll catch up i'll catch up
with you come on oh god i'm making it
happen
oh god i'm the wrong one but i need
someone to help me i can't i'm too far
away now
[ __ ] oh okay cool all right let me get
the let me get the camera
okay okay here we go are you ready you
want to wait you want to win no we can
go
wait for me okay we can make it we can
make
and then we're going to wait and here we
go all right do the next one gonna wait
wait we're gonna wait we're gonna wane
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that actually scared the [ __ ] out of me
here comes the dummy balloon for the
dummy
you know what i want it give it to me oh
it's kind of heavy
yep there we go you
[ __ ] dude again
by the time no wait don't do it again
wait
do not bob what's happening i'm trying
to dodge weight here
no oh no i'm sinking oh dear
well that's a death is the best option
come with me all right
i got i got i got y'all i got y'all i
got you okay wait
now you have to do it yourself you have
to get hey here here
here's a hand oh no he's got another
side he's got it he's got he's got it oh
bob you [ __ ] speed demon get the [ __ ]
away from me
okay yeah yeah
no one's touching me
jesus work like team you're supposed to
work like team
i will literally chuck you over the edge
every chance you give me
oh guys no right now oh right there we
go
i gotta go
i i had to i can't
listen i i told you what i was gonna do
and then i did it and i have no regrets
about it wait he's out oh
god damn it god damn it all right wait
we got this okay oh this is a big level
okay now all right i'm gonna get out of
your way i'm just going over here
okay we got this wave you and me buddy
you and me buddy
you and me pal you and me powell okay
now okay
no no no no no
yeah you guys are welcome for the
checkpoint yeah yeah yeah thanks man
you're welcome oh god
why hey bob hey
let's get out of here i was gonna get
weighed oh mama wade why there
why why would you grab there hey wait
don't
you don't leave me with this man
what do you mean death is better death
is better it's faster oh i got the
checkpoint hell yeah dude no we don't
need it wait we don't need it
we got the checkpoint wait we don't need
it yeah i earned the checkpoint
back is sore from carrying you [ __ ] i
don't know what you were thinking wade
hi
hello
oh my god i'm down here oh my god hey
i'm down here hey
how's it going here give me your head
don't let me die don't let me die
don't let me die
oh hey mark hey what's up hey mark we
have kind of a situation here if you
could help me let
me let go okay wait let go
oh no well oh i did it
scary isn't it i didn't
[Laughter]
don't
oh [ __ ] wait get up get off get off get
up
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] you could have
let go at any time i was not holding on
that's the thing i was actually not
holding on would you guys get off this
freaking platform you
oh jack i need to go i need to go we
need to work together i will launch you
wait get off wait get get off okay thank
you i am not on you
i'm over here this is the wrong way to
go up
oh
[Music]
help me who has me i it's me way
oh no i'm orange i'm going for it i'm
going for it wait it's coming
wait oh wait this is a bad idea give me
the coin okay
take the coin go back go back go back
[Laughter]
get out of my way get what are you doing
why have you done this
[Applause]
guys i won the ring
i just want to know why
and by the time i realized why you were
freaking out it was too late to fix
it oh my god oh my god
i'm going for this coin i'm going for it
i've got it oh you you're so dead i'm
not dead
because watch this oh god
ah my arm's tangled i'm a heart oh god
okay all right i'm going for it baby
he's going for it baby
here comes
[Laughter]
i know
maybe that'll catch the coin for you no
it won't because
that's a dumb idea okay just kind of
okay come on a little more a little more
go go drop drop
oh god all right
okay here i go guys here i am i'm here
you are so close to getting that coin
i'm gonna count it for you
thank you i'm gonna give you credit
i got teamwork okay i got it i got it i
got it get it
i got it i got it i got jesus this is
not working
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay wait i've got it we've got it
bridged yeah you guys let's go
you guys oh wait you guys hold it
actually we're gonna hold it guys look
at the coin we're gonna hold it
we're gonna hold it the coin we're gonna
hold it you get the coin we got it oh
my gosh oh god you're sliding slides
oh my god yes holy [ __ ]
how the hell do we pull that off so well
i didn't grab
anything you guys just water slided me
in there that was dope
oh okay all right okay you can't see me
i'm at
guys i did it wait i'm gonna give you a
dum-dum balloon oh
[ __ ] i'm sorry
[Music]
dunked myself that was so perfect wait i
would have had
the coin if you hadn't been such an
[ __ ]
ooh there i go i got it oh i got you i
got you
okay i'm gonna go oh him on the left
side wait where's he at
he's right here he's he's got it he's in
the balloon okay
oh god okay wait give me the coin give
me the
top give me the coin drop it drop it
drop drop it drop it down okay you're in
yeah
oh i
[Laughter]
i've got a headache from laughing so
hard i've got a headache from dealing
with you wade
okay he's a [ __ ] liability
no no no no no no oh no
jesus christ okay okay okay i'm holding
the coin i got it
[ __ ] the coin you get erect boys
oh god oh okay whoa wait come back jack
i'm sorry
okay okay okay did it we did it
we lost the
how did we lose the coin it hit the
spike that's what it was
oh god oh this ain't good oh grab things
oh boy
okay i've got weight i guess oh
let's do this hey the coin wait we gotta
go get the coin
oh where am i going no
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait i'm trying to
go back to the coin why are you doing
this to me i i [ __ ] up my hands
here let me get in position and i'll go
i got you okay
oh god all right here i'll grab it grab
it back okay okay
grab my hand i got your head the spikes
the spikes
the spikes the spikes the spikes there's
there's more
the other way just let it go wheeling
down
down all right see you guys oh god
why is this happening to me
you [ __ ] you didn't listen you said
swing down
yeah sweet swing
he's gonna do it to me too he's gonna do
it to me
he killed bob and now he's going to kill
me
all right you got it here we go yeah
here we go
hey guys i was readjusting my grip
thumbnail balloon i don't need it oh
wait oh i got
it away okay i got i got i'm on it i'm
at you come on
here i come here come here where'd the
coin go what do i have
wait okay send me back send me back send
me back to me
[Laughter]
that's doable i got it i got it we can
do this we can do this okay
okay just go just [ __ ] go oh
got it i haven't got it what a [ __ ]
wizard now i'm here i'm here to receive
you sir
receive i can help you come here leave
me alone
i got you i got you all right we got you
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute all right go go go go
okay i got let go bye-bye
[Laughter]
you unbelievable all right well now
you're gonna get to witness this
mastery this you're holding me
why would i be holding you what is that
why is there anything i'm about to make
farts he's gonna fart and block the
screen
[ __ ] if you guys give me a damn balloon
oh yeah wait i forgot i'm over here
left and right he can't be bothered i'm
coming in hot boys
okay i'm coming to receive nevermind i
was really hot
all right all right yourself don't don't
even help me
i got it don't worry about it first try
new record
we did it you did it we all did it
this [ __ ] oh no did these all spin
everybody for himself
no i'm on wave not a thing oh my god no
please oh hey mark
need i'm getting some speed
oh thank god there you go oh i'll let
you
i'll let you oh oh oh oh
god why oh god oh my god
all right well this well do you want to
swing or what shot
yeah okay ah
i think we meant i think we thought oh
there you go the same thing but
oh no oh [ __ ] yeah did you just see that
did you witness that
[Applause]
it's
[Music]
hey look who got here first losers where
am i
you're writing on the success of better
men oh for [ __ ] sake
wait coin coin coin give me a question
oh yeah mark if you could just touch it
and drop it i know i gotta catch it
yeah i'm in it i'll be like i'll be like
oh my god that death spike one is
terrible oh my god
smacked off me oh no
okay i got the balloon and
uh
[Applause]
first try hey i pulled together
oh hey sean
[Music]
oh my god
okay hey guys all right i let go of you
you let go of me
there you go there you go they go oh
okay
oh my god whoa wait there's invisible
stuff to grab there's invisible stuff to
grab hold me out hold me out
oh no okay um i'm holding that guy
i have an idea oh okay
what um we're cutting on something way
easier way to do
this mark let go of me uh okay
well if i did what you could have done
than that if we died why would you
die we were
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
oh and we did it
yeah good job teamwork we're all here
we're all here baby
can i get out and go help him or
something what are we forgetting
something
i'll i'll dumb them let me lift me oh
god i will be doing the dumb dumbs okay
wait wait you got this way i honestly
need someone to come help you
because i will do this for you oh no
[ __ ] come on my head
no you're out here wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait dude all right let's do
this
come on boys i got you boys left words
yep easy easy not too hot not too fast
not too fast
easy easy easy easy easy clap okay oh my
god i can grab
anything that's not the balloon all
right let the balloon go let go
i thought i told you i got you okay
climb climb around or grab me here and
let the balloon go oh my god
if you die oh whoa okay i've got you
i've got you i've got you
oh jesus christ wade you are a
helpless baby i'm beginning to see a
pattern with these levels
hey i won the one time remember
yeah because we built the [ __ ] line
for you yeah the one time you stole them
oh i see ah interesting interesting
interesting very interesting right
okay here we go i'm just tangled up on
oh oh [ __ ] oh hey there's a wall here or
something
but bob i should grab mark i don't know
what you grab up here hang on
here we go
[Applause]
all right teamwork
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh we can get the coin yeah let's go
wait will you help us get the coin oh
[Applause]
[ __ ] me there we go oh
okay this is a fun
i have us i have us i have okay we gotta
go around to the other side we gotta go
around we cannot let go of anyone
okay or anything
you're welcome guys
don't you don't you [ __ ] go okay here
we go
oh okay that's not promising i'm gonna
help you to call my ass
there we go i helped throw me daddy
where are you guys going
oh let me go oh oh god
okay go hey yay
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
got it get off of me get that freaking
frick off i'm going to kill us all
swear to god
okay
there we go okay anything over here nope
uh surprise mark you and i need mark
grab the bottom one
you and i can reposition and try and get
the coin maybe okay all right there we
go
yes okay let's oh okay
oh my god we're still swinging ah
just oh wait there's a thing over there
there's a thing over there
okay slowly slowly slowly slowly slowly
oh come on somewhere there we're too
jiggly
giggly bouncy i think and got it okay
i'm letting
go who's got that let me try and get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay got it oh hell yeah gamers
well yeah gamers i'm part of this club
okay
behind but i was crucial there well old
wait he wants to drag all the rest of us
down
are you kidding me i want us to win
together not
at all oh my sweet goodness oh there
i go okay our sacrifice is worth it i'm
gonna go for a bold stratagem
i caught you bob hey friend oh that's
really not what i wanted let go of me
thank you okay this is interesting wait
don't look on me
oh it's another slope
it's like a square you have to climb
around the bottom of it
my god you guys suck thank you thank you
god thank you i'm gonna get the coin
here guys why am i just falling into
perpetual death now
because you suck all right someone needs
to come down in here and uh
i got you yeah okay and then i grab
marek's hand
here oh here or bob yeah i'm on the top
now i'm on the top now
i can grab somebody wait get just leave
okay i got you i got you i got you okay
wait wait please wait
wait wait wait get please
wait lean up lean up wait go
oh my god wait oh you it's so
debilitated now i've got it i'm just
moving to the end
i've been let go now what the hell wait
let go
oh god don't leave me with this idiot
don't leave me with this city
with me don't leave me with this idiot
you're ready yeah yeah
i got you buddy wait what do you mean
you got me start moving
let us uh on the next peak just let go
we'll coast
oh good we got gamers i got it
yeah okay and we're dropping it just
let's just go in the hole oh [ __ ]
oh god oh god oh god help help
up
that was scary yeah but
wait for the team oh [ __ ] oh i almost
got you
that's my bad oh this is a swing oh
thank you
how are you doing mark i'm waiting for
wade
aren't we all come on guys
hi you get my hand we need to um get uh
whatever you do don't take his hand take
my little head i got your left hand jack
you go oh
[Music]
very quickly get away from him okay we
got him we got away from him
hey take my hand wait hang on like grab
the right come on take my hand
no guys what about the coin [ __ ] the
coin
okay i'm great news i'm grabbed oh thank
you
okay okay
take my hand take my hand okay
we did it all right let go of me i want
to give way to save your balloon
you do that i gotta i gotta go to the
bathroom see if he kills himself on this
part
my balloon is helpful i got you wait
oh boy [ __ ] why why
i got shy oh okay oh
see ya okay square one get his hand get
his hand
or let him grab your dick oh oh okay
wait let go let go no you can't you
don't know
uh
[Laughter]
he's got it you can get that coin if
you're feeling real
just gonna wait just go just go no get
the coin bro get the coin i'm back did i
miss anything
no you missed a glitch where he just got
crushed against the side of the screen
over here
all right i'm going this way in case it
[ __ ] crushes me again all right yeah
i know that i
trust that it wouldn't do it twice
everyone in chat knows that i shouldn't
have died there i was i was home free to
be fair that was [ __ ] i don't know
what happened
yeah yeah that was weird i agree wade
now could we go back to some [ __ ]
team working out this like
wade's bad [ __ ] i've been good i've
saved your asses so many times i got the
coin
i'm so good to be fair yeah you are
oh god wait a minute holy [ __ ]
no okay oh no all right
it's gonna this is i think we need to be
a big old clump
i think this is how you win it look
we're so [ __ ] fast
let me go let me go let me go let me go
let me go let me go oh
no oh
and then grab it can we stop jesus
christ i don't know
i don't know hey good enough let's try
and grab them okay
okay okay okay we're going to stop you
ah
all right good now now yeah but now one
cool
okay you have to grab the other thing
you need to grab the left we stop the
momentum
oh whoa whoa okay okay i don't think i'm
holding on to anyone or anything
so we get max range out of it i'm just
riding you right now sorry
i don't know what to do about this oh no
not like this we got it we got it
oh no no no no no no no no
okay okay okay here we go okay okay i'm
going to calm down here i'm going to
stop doing that i'm going to call him
yeah we can like balance ball it so we
just need to be chill
let go let go what happens chill
okay oh [ __ ] shh notice right here he
goes
grab it
[Laughter]
okay that's really working now
this music is app pull me in pull me in
pull me in
listen i'm really at a loss of what to
do here don't pull me
oh i i deserve
i don't know i wanted the coin yeah we
could have gotten the coin we could have
gotten the coin
i hope that's the only level ever
getting the coin would have been a
bolder
move than what we did what is happening
it's upside down fuji
all right don't you bring me into this
whatever this is you brought me into
this
how are you you're in the middle i mean
you brought me into this
you think i just voluntarily got in the
middle somehow everyone grabbed my hands
and i was in the middle
oh
i'm sorry i deserve that i deserve that
that's mine i deserve that i didn't
though
well let's stop me no don't touch me i
don't want any i'm not going to
participate
i think that's going to be easier one on
one one by one yeah i'm going to go get
this thing
left i'm going to go get this thing um
don't no i've got this i've got this
guys
all right yeah we got this we got this
oh you absolute garbage animals
oh bob you get the coin bob gets going
give me a balloon
wait what i was already going for wait
what the hell
i don't know wait wait wait no mr
balloon wait wait wait wait how we call
it a balloon but it's more of a life
preserver
whatever it's a balloon oh don't don't
don't i match the orientation of the
level
swoop nice green guy yeah good
i need your assistance yeah you do i
don't need your assistance
yeah you do let go of the blue no i do
not hold over bob i will believe myself
to save me
okay guys i got the coins
guys you see i got the coin yeah i did
it i don't watch your
kind of help that's a little rude guys
teamwork
dreams and teams
[Music]
i'm gonna do this
boy okay
okay i guess i'm gonna just uh hey guys
how's it going
hey all right okay there we go there we
go that's good that's good that's good
that's good bring it
around bring her around bring her around
i think you can let go
let go of your left hand don't get off
of me grab him
grab him i have him okay going around
and i've got the queen oh do the thing
oh no no wait let go of me you [ __ ]
ass
momentum the momentum up up
up up what do you mean oh me
up oh okay okay
[Laughter]
i feel like there's a fundamental
misunderstanding of group momentum here
oh
[Laughter]
my blood pressure can't take this guys
okay wait you're gonna need to like go
with your right hand you're holding on
to the ball done
okay here we go oh god bring it around
bring it down
all right oh [ __ ] we're gonna have to do
another we're gonna have to do another
hand switch before we can go for the
coin
okay we gotta pull it up and then sean
you're gonna oh
okay okay you got it you got me got me
this is better this is better we fixed
it
oh god we can't we can't get the coin
sean you're gonna have to be the one on
the ball okay
you will have to bring you around and
then we need to be
[Applause]
hey let's go this worked this is
this is terrible again no we need to let
it work out yeah i'd like to get out
please don't look don't let me out here
oh my god all right chill chill
chill chill you have it okay i'm letting
go of it
here we go okay
come on well i'm glad you made it out of
that
i don't know you don't sound very glad
this is the worst level ever
wait which end am i on the end yeah yeah
yeah there we go
there you go
come on it's jesus christ
okay
[Music]
yeah sorry that's my bed i let go
prematurely
got it where's your left okay i got you
god goddamn
lower lower
got it i think
that one might that one might have been
my bad guys how about we just get to the
exit we forget about the
[ __ ] the coin all right all right all
right america i have your right okay
now flip hand over hand shot jack hand
over head hand over hand the other way
you got to go
you got to go over it oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah
well there he goes [ __ ]
oh god oh okay we're going now boys
here we go we got what do you mean no
what do you mean no what do you mean no
we gotta go slow go away go right for
the right oh my god
stop fighting this wade
jesus christmas perfect okay
up and around up and around up here wait
up to the right get on the ball
get on the ball oh wait get on the ball
wrap around and get on the ball i'm
trying
i'm not the one controlling this yes you
are
oh my god
wait wait is the problem no you are the
one that is fighting
the wrong way you're the only one
someone is framing me you are the only
one
we need to do this in groups of two or
something you see how you see look
look at me look at me look at me look at
i want to teach
i want to teach way look at me you see
how i i'm moving this way and the ball
is moving that way
you didn't do that you oh my god i was
told
wait you got on and it got way worse
okay wait i can't get on now
let go of your right hand and grab my
hand
there we go we're going with my hand so
we're going to go over this way
and we're going to pull this way we're
going to go this way
and we're going to go a little bit
the most dysfunctional couple you're
gonna be the one that's gonna grab it
you're gonna be the ones
[Laughter]
what do you mean help him if he can't do
this himself he hasn't earned it
i haven't learned how to do it yet there
you go i sh i'm going
wait hang on all right we got this
we got this take my hand yep yep the
wrong one no
i don't know mark after watching work
that'll work that'll work pretty good
yeah we did good we did good wade i'm
very proud of you thank god
swinging us oh
sweet mother of [ __ ] jesus oh my god
see you away
[ __ ] get in here i'm trying because
you're swinging me like a madman
probably the thing was just watch back
to the end
that was amazing that's so ridiculous
and then i got myself too
oh boy all right geez i'm beginning to
not like this game anymore
what do you mean what do you mean hey
guys we got the coin if you guys want to
know
i'm gonna try and work with you wade
let's do this
get up there okay this is a [ __ ]
weird one
yeah this one's gonna be tough all right
[Music]
oh god oh god guys guys
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good okay dum-dum dum-dums coming
in
dumb dog what in the world
all right here we go all right mark
let's do this let's do it we're out of
here baby
careful yeah actually
i want to move my hand up to the right
okay like wait yourself
do whatever he's about to do okay wait
you can probably launch yourself if you
get enough momentum
if you drop on our balloon weight i
swear to god
[Laughter]
all right carefully carefully carefully
hang on all right you guys are great
holy [ __ ] our balloon
oh it's balloon it's like save how we
made it in on that one and
my hand hurts so bad from clinching the
stupid controller
gotta relax man oh no oh god
there he goes oh there i go
all right we're going down here oh god
oh jack don't
wait [ __ ]
oh
sitting on us holding us down okay
all right oh can we need a little bit
more extension
no it's fine sorry
oh my gosh let me extend it someone let
go of the left hand
someone let go oh not that left hand
grab my head hey come here i'm playing
an arizona iced tea level
i don't care i don't care i got you i
think right okay yeah you got me oh hey
oh yeah oh this is a problem
get off of us i'm so close
stop sucking me up
okay all right i'm gonna stay behind i
think
okay no you're not you're coming with a
oh god please
do not american body whatever you're
thinking of doing
either you don't know
just go just go for it just just go
oh okay well okay wait let go let go let
go
let go left left okay
you can make do you guys know how to
move those balls
okay i could use [ __ ]
we both let go at the same time
oh god there's a lot of assistance oh
you really jumped on there
there you go there you go there you go
oh
so hard
hey what's up douchebags hey how's it
going you guys having fun here
oh wow looks like you're making a lot of
progress oh no
oh that sucks wow
this is great get it get it get it get
it
get it you get it i don't i got it i got
it i got it okay
all right cool we got everything one one
two three
four yeah we're here hey look at dum dum
are you [ __ ] kidding me
can you make that coin easier if i do
this all right wait how are you going to
put that balloon
up there yeah easy
no no no are you [ __ ] kidding me
don't worry about it i can get you all
the dum-dum balloons
you gotta grab it on the circle i think
and then just like ease it in
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna grab on the two
you can do it you can do it help
no i i'm not go wait get away you
another one no
there's nobody i'm doing it i didn't
make it
oh mark it's okay i'll be there in a
second oh god
yeah how am i supposed to move the ball
now okay are you [ __ ] kidding me how
grab my hand
brother how do i move this [ __ ] ball
easily i gotta gotta hold it to the
right and then flip up and around with
the momentum and then keep holding it to
the right
[ __ ] you use the balloon you can use the
balloon grab my hand oh actually i'll
move
this one out of the way for you mark i
moved at the wrong time
listen i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna move this
one out of the way for you
what happened i look man okay hey we're
here okay we can do this together
okay we're gonna get this
all of a sudden working with old weight
he doesn't look too bad does it i'm
not talking to you wade
at all huh there we go and flip over
flip over we gotta go one more
revolution
we gotta no not this way we gotta do the
same thing we just did again
we gotta get the momentum and now we
flip oh [ __ ] balloon
pop it pop it pop it you're good and
momentum and flip
flip up and then now okay here we go
we're gonna pull it all right
and i'm gonna extend out and grab that
get my hand
why was my hand caught on my body
i don't know that was [ __ ]
[Laughter]
balloon all right you got this
the balloon on this level is such a trap
yeah there we go and then i got this
do you guys need any assistance no we're
fine
i'm gonna help okay here we go my taint
all right you go just go just go no jack
stay there be chill be chill no i can do
this by myself i got it i can i can i
can hold on
you cannot do that i can do it by myself
why is my guy swinging so hard swinging
for god's sake
stop swinging i'm trying i'm literally
not pressing anything
there we go here we go oh god it's not
working i can't do it by myself
that's what we thought wait shut up i'm
not talking to you
oh hi you need me don't you what no
i'll come save you buddy okay here we go
oh god oh bob oh bob
you're right you're right you're right
you're right i don't know how
uh i got you i got you okay i'm gonna
let go of my right
okay [ __ ] everything is fine of course
i'm fine i'm really good hear me so much
i'm
excellent at this don't even worry about
me okay let go of your right
my hand hurts not that was your left
other right don't worry guys okay cool
good
you wanna come back i can come back to
help okay i have bob
who do you know this is terrible
bumping around up and around up up
[Laughter]
here we go and got it oh okay oh
okay bob where you're gonna let go we're
gonna slap on to this ball
oh come on it's fine go forward let's
get you to the end let's get to the end
gotcha oh this is what it feels like
all right i'm coming back for you bud
that's the wrong hand
uh-huh there you go okay can you let go
of right or left
you got this oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right
you come up this level yeah okay we're
good let me move my hand
okay gotcha oh okay thanks wayne thanks
you always not too high
not too fast oh god i know how to do it
oh jesus
i'm married yeah there should be a mode
where the level clears when one person
makes it okay
we did it we beat the game we did it
oh no rope oops no no no
no no more no more no more no more no i
wanted that
okay look at that thank yourself okay
wow i my hands hurt so bad
i feel like i could just got a workout
you guys needed me in the end
admit it to watch us finish the level
without you at all
excuse excuse excuse me
75 of that you were trying to kill us
and it was
i was never trying to kill you then you
were so inept that you were killing us
accidentally you can't deny that one way
you can't deny that one
[Music]
you